smart is on Leonard that's a chance to
be a fun matchup jaylen brown on told
George that's a fun matchup as well to
box to Leonard shot clock to three four
shot is good but what do they see when
they get to the rim and what is their
decision-making when they do so well
George launches a parade laughs at him
we asked for a trade from Indiana the
first team on his list was the Spurs now
they're actually teammates and have been
bonding off the cortisol seasons and
fishing trips rotate in the faint Celtic
shooting under 40% but they still lead
and even after that Bri still lead by
one but Leonard knocks down his second
three-pointer
perfect thank you Joe there's nothing
worse than an unnatural bounce Paul
George with the rejection played the
three in the fourth for Pittsburgh right
tough-minded defensive program but I
never saw him as an NBA player while
George knocks it down
who buys rebounds the miss they really
rely on Paul George will stroll down the
lane
George kicks it out beautifully nobody
anywhere [ __ ] Trenor
two very good defensive plays by Kawhi
Leonard fakes and a pull-up line drive
is careful
George with a hand that has faced that
it's got eight rebounds tonight George
drives right at ice gets knocked down a
lot of contact they let him play on the
line six times and take six three is
you're gonna up your scoring average
over 20 and it's proved completely
accurate you Telegraph that pass Beverly
in the corner
[Applause]
Beverly corner tray from Italy outlet to
George George on the drive inside Harold
banks it home it's a two-point game
not play Leonard or George passed the
minutes I don't know I don't think so I
think right now that's the number one
thing as George puts up another brand
this time nails it and the Clippers go
up one George kicks it out Beverly
another corner three another family pegs
Johnson puts time Doc Rivers has a
timeout remaining Celtics do not smart
will inbound and the Clippers hang on
the moon in OT